>SI RALLYING00 NEW IS NOANAS F
THEY WER O
LDBADOLD B ACCORDANCE WITH   IN
HAMPSHIRE.
>> LADIES AN
ACCORDANCE WHAMPSHIRE
EC ORDER 63, PLEASEEAURAS
OBLES THERE.
RYAN, TO BE CL NNG ARE
BREAKING THE  IHERE YOU ARE
STAN WHAT YOU'RE SIN'S , YOU'RE.
NOT O  IT'S IN DIRECT OOSPRESID
LI.
STATE OF NEW
HAMPSHIRTHXECUTIVE HAT SSE GROU
YOU VE WEARI MASK.
IT'S N A O TRUMP DID T WALKED
AND APLAY TFT
RE T MASK
ABSENT OF THAT SOMNEMA N TOLD T
TO ON.
THERE NO LAWORCEMENT
ING THE THEM ,DASAW MORE ANDF T
PRESIDENT SUPPORTERS TAKE EI OFH
THEIMAGINATION.
MOST OF THEE HERE ARE NOT
IMPORTANT, IN THIS IS
JUST REAYEG OF THE
PRESINT
D IN HIS CAMPAIGN HAS
SA GOING ON THE R HOLAVE TOISCE
COUNTRMUCH.
>>> DR. GS
YOU HEAR A CROWD BOOINGNLDEOPLEE
IF PEOMASKS.
>> WELL IMEAN, WHAT GOES
THROUGH MYT  THESE PEO DON'T
THINK THIS IS REAL.
THEY THINKAN STILLTHINKT' HOAX.
ASKING TOO WEAR AASKOUGH
WE'R IID
PANDEMIC ANDUPOL STARTED O THIN
UCIAL.
'SONEARLY 70,000
SAVED.
YOUCHANCE TO  MOVEMENT
TO SE,000 LIVES YOU I'M
DO IT.
THDISC TO MOST
LE DON'T TNK Y. TOIE NATIVE DO N
THAT BUT PEO BOOINGTHEY'R TO SO
NEXT TO THEM GETTING  DISURS AT.
THIS RALLY TONIGHT WIT
OI BEING HELD ON THE SAME
NWASHINGTON.
WE SWD
RMTHERE WEREEANG MAS
THENDIFFERENT.
BUT AHER OF THESE
H TOCIALLY
>> NO OTHRRY SK
THERE ISO Q ABOUT ITIN THE MIDDP
HAVI AINE TOGRIS SOMETHING VIRU
VERY CH. VIRUS LIKESO JUMPERSON.
IT'S NOT ADE M
OBJEIVELY SPEAKIOU
GOOD  OVERALL A WEARING A MAS MT
REALLY KE? QUESTION.
THERE HAVE BEE ONTHIS.AS B SIX
THAT'S SIGNIFICAF Y
ABOUT IT.
THERE IS SOMETHING ELSE.
WHAT COUNTS ASLONTIF YOU'RE SIT
TEN OMINUTES, THAT'SSE
NTERCHING
THAT'SBE.
OBJECTY SPEAKING,
Y TIME YOUPLE TOGETHER
IN THE A PA HISTORYKSTE